growing old it's one of the
inevitabilities of human existence or is
it there's one question on everybody's
lips is it possible to live forever
from fad diets to going under the knife
the pursuit of Eternal youth is as old
as time itself and modern science has
brought it little closer
exercising the mind and body is a great
way to prevent aging but despite our
best efforts some of us age much faster
than others in various and unpredictable
ways other people don't want to live
healthy lives well into their 90s even
Beyond and it's that fact that's given
scientists the confidence to see aging
rather than the inevitability as a set
of biological processes that can be
slowed stopped or even reversed
so who's going to hack aging as we know
it it's really only one place to look
a few things better in body the pursuit
of Eternal youth than Californian Beach
culture but what is it about the West
Coast that's attracted a boom in
anti-aging research well some scientists
believe the roots of Aging are all in
our genetic code essentially a software
problem and who better to fix that than
Silicon Valley
no serious scientist is pursuing
immortality but what is in our grasp are
drugs to Target some of the key drivers
of Aging like how our muscles or brain
cells wear out over time
rather than peering into Petri dishes or
looking at lab animals this might take
company is taking a very different
approach to trying to find human
specific drivers of aging and then doing
that by using computer power to sit
through vast databases and biological
samples to try and find common factors
among people who live very long healthy
lives compared to those who die much
younger and they're already finding some
promising tolerance so personally I
don't think there's any one silver
bullet for aging any one pill or Gene
you can hit that will you know rewind
the clock 20 years I do believe though
that there are a couple dozen targets
and Pathways that we can hit that
together can have a really dramatic
effect on lifespan and health span
is aging the latest example of Silicon
Valley hype some dismiss the new
interest in the fields are Bid by the
privilege to pursue immortality
could live up to another promise
providing Millions worldwide the
prospect of lives that don't end with a
decade or more of chronic illness
spare Society The Soaring costs of
caring for an ever-growing aging
population
[Music]